i was excited to be at outcast studio
the other night
i just being they went oh that
i was shocked when i went there too i
ain't never met big boy he walked
through stankonian
oh my god history he sat here i remember
my first time
going this before i even got signed my
first time going to florida
but um change took me there
and uh i walk in
and it was like yeah bro that's the
pillow he used he passed out on and
that's the couch and this [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
grabbing this [ __ ] like damn this [ __ ]
this old
and i already love history you feel me
so to be in there like down looking yeah
up there with the [ __ ] who i really
admire when they come to the music [ __ ]
right that was five
nah yeah outcast is my they're my
favorite they're like
andre top three for me and cass is the
greatest rap group
he represented for the people in the
south showing him that we more than just
shoot him up bang bang donk's riding
like him mm-hmm
we feel me yeah i think it's dope that
yeah like you said like
outcast i kind of look at the way like
tde and kendrick is to la
there you go you know what i'm saying
there you go that's what outcast did for
the south first
you know